spider-man is back in the MCU after a
lot of renegotiations between Sony and
Disney we are officially getting a
spider-man 3 set in the MCU and just a
couple of years and it appears that the
script for it has been leaked what's up
everyone it's Warren and yes you heard
correctly apparently the script for
spider-man 3 has been leaked revealing
the villains revealing the plot and some
familiar heroes as well so let's jump
into it but first be sure to subscribe
if you love Marvel content and you'd
like a chance to win at Xbox one or a
ps4 and also an infinity saga
collector's box to enter all you have to
do is be subscribed with the
notifications turned on leave a like and
leave a comment down below and more on
that at the end so this plot leaked is
very detailed and could very well be
real so spoiler alert if you would like
to avoid anything related to the next
spider-man film so the movie starts off
with Peter Parker being raided and
arrested by the cops and SWAT team at
his home he is then taken to court and
he has tried and sentenced to life with
no possibility of parole in a
maximum-security prison much of the
first act as Peter going to court the
court proceedings and then him being
taken to prison once Peter gets to
prison it shows him trying to adjust to
life in prison but then all of the
convicts and even some of the guards
start trying to kill him now one thing
to note here is that nowhere doesn't
mention a lawyer there's been a lot of
talk that Jennifer Susan Walters or
she-hulk could be his attorney or
somebody that's even more exciting Matt
Murdock aka daredevil unfortunately at
this point in the plot League there is
no mention of either of them now that
doesn't mean that they're not going to
be in the movie it just means that
they're not mentioned right here but in
prison basically everybody is trying to
kill Peter Parker so Peter soon finds
out that there was a huge contract put
out on him from somebody on the outside
calling himself the benefactor now if
you're wondering why the benefactor
sounds so familiar it's because we've
heard this name two times before one is
from ant-man and the wasp Sonny Burch
mentions a mysterious benefactor and the
second time that we've heard the
benefactor was for a supposed
post-credit scene for spider-man far
from home now nobody really knows if
there was an original post-credit scene
for spider-man far from home that
involved this mysterious benefit
that was supposed to set up the sinister
six but some people do claim that a post
credit scene did exist for spider-man
far from home that had the benefactor in
it so Peter learns that this so-called
benefactor has put out a hit on Peters
life that's why everybody is trying to
kill him in prison even the guards a
massive brawl ends up breaking out
leading to Peter being transferred to a
different prison the bus carrying him
and other prisoners is intercepted in
the middle of the city by Kraven the
Bounty Hunter Kraven coldly kills the
prisoners and Dukes it out with Peter
Peter manages to escape Kraven but he is
very badly beaten he is free but now as
a fugitive from the law and is being
chased by people who want him dead and
if you're wondering who the benefactor
is don't worry this plot leaked does
reveal it so Peter is now on the run and
he disconnects himself from everybody
that he knows he only reaches out to
happy via a payphone to ask him for help
if possible and to leave a message for
his friends and family but besides from
that he has absolutely no help at all we
go on to find out that this mysterious
benefactor is actually Mysterio himself
Quentin Beck he's still alive and
working behind the scenes to get rid of
spider-man before returning as the
renowned Mysterio now I knew the fandom
was split about 50/50 on whether or not
they actually believed Mysterio was dead
I actually didn't and still don't think
he's dead he is a master of illusion I
think the end was just an illusion now
much of the second act is really a
cat-and-mouse game between spider-man
and Kraven and he spends much of the
movie without any web-shooters he does
get a new suit but it's one that he hand
makes and it's not very good we find out
that this is Cravens first time being
tasked to kill a superhuman and he's
having fun with it almost taking it easy
and just sort of toying with spider-man
so Peter gets caught in a race between
trying to clear his name upon
discovering that Quentin Beck is still
alive and also trying to avoid the law
and Kraven along with other small-time
hitman and villains who pop up along the
way and this is where the plot leak
starts to get very interesting
introducing new characters Peter
eventually gets back in touch with happy
and happy points Peter in the direction
of agent Jessica drew agent Jessica drew
believes that Peter is innocent and
she's willing to help keep Kraven off of
his tail happy also manages to get Peter
his web-shooters back and man
just to get him his old original
homecoming suit Quinton Beck aka
Mysterio becomes increasingly frustrated
with Cravens failure to kill spider-man
but we find out that it's actually
Cravens last hunt see what they did
there as he has been diagnosed with
terminal cancer and he is savoring it
savoring his final kill but as it turns
out he honestly just doesn't want to
kill a kid and this kind of makes sense
because Kraven isn't necessarily a
villain he's kind of like venom he's not
really a villain per se but he's not
necessarily a hero he's kind of an
antihero so Kraven not wanting to kill a
kid makes sense but Quentin Beck
threatens to kill Kraven if he doesn't
get the job done now although it doesn't
talk about it in this plot leak it does
sound like Mysterio has some sort of
power over Kraven perhaps he promised
Kraven something that could help him or
perhaps someone in his family but it
sure does sound like he has some type of
control over him rather than just giving
him money to kill somebody but we have
another twist we find out that Quentin
Beck himself has a benefactor and this
benefactor is none other than Norman
Osborn that's right the Green Goblin
himself and we find out that Norman
Osborn is running to be a senator now
although Quentin Beck is working for
Norman Osborn Norman eventually exposes
Beck as a fraud and proves Peter
Parker's innocence now Norman Osborn if
you know him doesn't really do anything
out of the goodness of his heart he did
this to make himself look good and did
this to help him in the election him
exposing the truth swings the public
opinion his way for the election he gets
the credit for reopening the
investigation and finding out the truth
about Peter Parker spider-man and
Mysterio but Kraven is still on the hunt
and the final battle between Kraven and
spider-man is brutal they get sandwiched
by the police and it ends in Kraven
nearly being killed by an extremely
angry Peter Parker Kraven tells Peter
where Beck is hiding and Peter lets him
live
of course we're not ever really going to
see spider-man kill anybody but
something to note is that spider-man 3
is said to be the darkest spider-man
that we've ever seen Peter is on the run
he's arrested he's put in prison
everybody is trying to kill him and we
don't have the normal characters like MJ
Ned flash and happy that normally
lighten up the situation and then after
with all of this in the film it seems
like he almost snaps and almost kills
Kraven which would make sense because
that's honestly just very realistic but
we're not done Peter goes into Beck's
hideout which ends up being a really big
illusion this scene is going to be very
much like the scene that we saw in
spider-man far from home where
spider-man takes on Mysterio for the
very first time although this time he
beats him and although Peter is
completely enraged he does not kill
Quentin Beck
he simply defeats him and the police
come and Quentin is arrested the police
seize all of Quentin Beck's evidence and
belongings and they find out that Peter
Parker is indeed innocent peter is
officially ruled innocent by the court
and is finally free of course at the end
Peter finally reunites with MJ Ned in
May and there are some happy moments
shared between all of them at the end
but the final scene is very interesting
Peter goes to visit dr. strange and
while he's there dr. strange offers to
make the world forget Peter Ponder's the
question and then the credits roll now
it's very curious as to what Doctor
Strange is offering to make people
forget is he offering to make people
forget that Peter Parker is spider-man
that way nobody would know the identity
of spider-man or is he offering to make
everybody forget everything that
happened with Mysterio because if that's
the case then that could probably create
some trouble but we do know that dr.
Strange's job is supposed to be
protecting reality so perhaps there's
something there that he could possibly
erase to help protect the reality that
they live in now there is no mention of
a post-credits scene but based off of
what the plot leaks said it seems like
we could probably get something relating
to the Green Goblin or the sinister six
and let's not forget what Amy Pascal the
former chairperson of Sony Pictures
Entertainment and the owner right now of
Pascal Pictures said very recently that
was her talking about the sinister six
she said that right now in this
spider-man universe that we have we
technically have all of the characters
that could make up the sinister six so
it appears that the sinister six are
coming eventually and this movie will
even throw in Kraven the hunter and if
Norman Osborn really is the mysterious
benefactor behind everything that we've
heard in the MCU so far he could
definitely get Quentin back out of
prison and he could recruit Kraven the
hunter as well now there has been a
lot of talk about a Kraven the hunter
solo film from Sony however of course
they just worked out a new deal with
Disney of course that idea was for
spider-man to remain in the MCU so
perhaps that deal could have affected
their decision to make it Kraven the
hunter movie or perhaps they're just
going to introduce him first in
spider-man 3 but it definitely seems
like spider-man 3 is going to set up at
least the introduction of Norman Osborn
into the MCU and the Green Goblin and
the Green Goblin being introduced as
well as the sinister six makes sense
because Spidey is back for two films we
know that the deal was for one other
solo movie and a crossover movie so the
really exciting news is that if he ends
up going up against the Green Goblin
slash Norman Osborn and the sinister six
it will most likely involve other heroes
based off of this plot leak it still
seems like he keeps in contact with
Doctor Strange it wouldn't be hard they
both live in New York they're probably
not too far from each other so it
wouldn't be hard for them to team up not
to mention some of the other Avengers
could come in as well so based on
everything this plot leaked has said
spider-man 3 sounds to be pretty dang
good and it sets up the next crossover
event for spider-man and other Avengers
so if this is what we end up getting for
the third spider-man film in the MCU I'm
ok with this I actually really like this
I like the return of Mysterio because I
don't believe that he's dead
I like the introduction of Kraven the
hunter and I like the introduction of
Norman Osborn I think it sets up the
future for spider-man in the MCU very
well which will make him stay a lot
longer which of course is what we all
want so let me know in the comments down
below if this is how spider-man 3 is
going to be do you like it if not what
would you change drop a comment down
below also don't forget to give this
video a like and be sure to subscribe to
my channel if you'd like to stay up to
date with the MCU and all things related
to marvel this also enters you in my
giveaway giving away an xbox one and a
ps4 and then after that I'll be giving
away in infinity saga collector's box
again all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel with the
notifications turned on like the video
and comment below my Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway is going to launch today as
well so I'll put a link to that in the
description down below and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof